Salam alaikum brothers and sisters say
we're in Hyde Park with John you know
the reverb brother I was talking about
my page basically I've lost my words
because I've been doing a lot of Dawa
without him
so as some really amazing happen
yesterday he was really amazing for me
you know you might watch this video and
think okay there's nothing much about
but really really me and Jennifer
because John John was there any kind of
witnessed it so we're gonna go through
how it happened how it all happened and
I and our way there and how it just all
happened to be honest so basically we
got on the train
yeah and from Walter new Stratford yeah
right
I mean I I'm from Manchester so I've
come down for a few days to work on our
projects and Matt was I early for the
first time so we're on our way to
Stratford to do some Dawa and Ali was
telling me that he's been doing Dawa
he's been Muslim for how long now about
11 months and he's been doing dollar for
how long well five months yeah and he
said that he's not seen a Shahada yeah
he's not actually witnessed a Shahada
and he was asking me like I kiss you
know he's been working very hard you
know giving dour and he's a bit getting
a bit down on you because you know he's
not seen any shahadat and basically I
asked him what you doing and he
concentrates mostly on debating
Christians and I never could relate to
the side a bit and I just advised him to
concentrate on his intention and also
make the wow this is the best advice and
when he focus on the intention and do it
solely for the sake of Allah then then
and ask Allah so we basically on the on
the train I advised him I said I'll
invite you advise you advised him making
tension you know that is for the sake of
Allah and make the wire so ask Allah and
so we made the wire and I said o Allah
if you want to guide anyone today
because only Allah can guide we can't do
anything if you want to guide anyone
bring them to brother Ali today and then
I totally make you do a specific right
so it's three o'clock in the afternoon
and then I said
oh Allah if you want to guide anyone
please bring them to Ali use ally in the
Dawa and bring them to Ali before four
o'clock okay so we've got one hour okay
so the second we got off and Ali was
just like yeah I just want to say yes
yes yes so like when he was telling me
you know like the power of du'a I'm
being honest my mom was a bit low and I
was like okay man you know I did I did I
put my hand up and I prayed and he was
that make it specific and say you know
before four o'clock and when he said
before four o'clock I was thinking to
myself it's like free it was like when
we got it was that it was my name's Mike
yes so I was thinking there's no way
because I'm gonna go and I'm gonna play
a sir and I was okay right yeah I didn't
really take it seriously but then we got
Stratford yeah yeah as soon as I got off
the train the first conversation I had
was with a Chinese girl and she accepted
Islam yeah she just accepted Islam she
she was originally she she'd been she
had converted to Christianity but then
when they explained the concept of Allah
and the concept of Allah in Islam then
she said that this this concept of God
makes more sense and she also she's been
doing some research into Prophet
Muhammad and hamdulillah she accepted
Islam so Ali was amazed he's like soap
on a lot like we made the dawah and
we've seen the shadow and then so then
what happens upon Allah I mean the point
why I was explaining the importance of
making dua I I was setting up at our
table in Manchester a college and I was
teaching his brother how to make
intention how to do Dawa so a sensitive
of a make intention okay to do it for
the sake of Allah so we made made
intention
we're gonna go there do for the sake of
Allah and if Allah wants to guide anyone
to bring them to us and shall I use us
and the the part where he made intention
is like a five minute walk from the
college okay so we went there we made
the wah
sorry Dawa and then when we coming back
to the Masjid the exact point in the
street where we made intention this guy
approaches me he says can I have a Koran
so I said are you Muslim and he said no
but I want to be and he just he just
accepts in Islam you know this is just
proving that guidance is from Allah
alone and when you understand this and
you put yourself out there and you
the son that your job is simply to give
a good message give the message of Islam
and and to and to invite people to tell
here to invite people to Islam then
Allah will use you and if he wants the
guy then we bring them to you yeah so
when we got to Stratford as I say we had
we heard the first shot and then
basically weapon was he told me this
story that was the way he took the tower
with make an intention making the door
and I I kind of listened here and I was
ok alright yeah it's possible so I
learned a lesson with what happened I'm
about to show you now so he did its
Shahada but the thing is I've never done
a shot I've been doing door for about
five months not a long time but I've
never attempted like do the shot a bit
so I prayed my I came back and was just
handing out leaflets and this brother
came with his wife and basically you see
his picture popping up on the screen and
he just came up and he was to the United
Nations and he lives in Italy all I did
was give him a leaflet and said brother
- you have two minutes and he said yeah
sure I have and the next thing I said to
him like do you believe in God do you
have a belief and he said yeah I believe
in God but my faith is a bit up and down
because because of you know the Bible
has kind of before she being changed so
he was honest with me and he said you
know this is the problem I had
so I told me about what Jesus really
taught in the Bible you know Jesus never
claimed to be different divine he never
said I am God or worship me I gave him
all that we did a bit of Dawa talked
about it and then I kind of hesitated
but said you know what let me try and
buy time I don't know what time it is
now I'm just I'm just talking to him and
I said bro like he agreed with a lot of
their stuff and I said bro you're a
Muslim we have to do just a Shahada way
and he said I was the Shahada
and the child is just like claiming that
there is nothing worthy of worship but
Allah Muhammad Allah and Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him is his
messenger and he just went yeah that's
fine it's just like he came there to
accept that not only that was why we
made on the train was Allah if he wants
a guy never bring them to us yes since
here is to say if you if you know any
sincere people bring them to us and
allow us to be the means you know next
yeah and so finally this guy came to
Olivia's and then you showed me over
yeah Jon Kubek yeah basically what
happened was when he said Allah said the
Shahada
we had a few Christian guys came over
trying to stop him you know saying you
know don't don't accept it how many was
there how many was it
anything that possibly could have gone
wrong yeah do you love this guy yes yes
it was like loads of born-again
Christians around those shouting don't
say it don't say yes you know you're
gonna go to hell don't leave Jesus
things like this yeah and this guy said
he just went he said no I'm ready to
accept that yeah look really to accept
apologies I've never seen so someone is
rare that you see someone so convinced
and ready to accept yeah so a weapon was
then I when he said I'll accept Shahada
because I was a bit baffled I was that
well and I called John John behind me
I said John just come here and tell them
what we talked about on the train I
didn't even look at you I didn't wanna
come and call you just in case your
finger whispered something to you I just
said John come here I looked away and
you just told them I mean I you know
that we and and he was surprised by it
and we confirmed the is belief in Allah
and the messenger you know he's also
doing his own research and then after
you know we act he accepts this so
afterwards I just happened to say to Ali
what time is it yeah I was there and he
just went what time is he talking have
to be lazy somewhere I what do you what
time is it and then this one a lot it
was 351 350 for four o'clock and I was I
was baffled because I was like no way
but that's a lesson for me because the
power of the war I didn't take that
seriously and I taught it taught me a
lesson I was from toilet telling me if I
will something it will happen and 3:51
briefing will of that the time 351 the
tactic I took my first shot harder it's
just it's just very important that we
understand that we need to make du'a and
we need to believe that these doors are
gonna be answered
you know we needs to be expecting them
to be answered and and I like to be
specific in my door yeah I like to you
know like I said four o'clock we had one
hour and so partly because that way you
know that specifically that the wire was
answered and Swala is amazing yeah and
and you you totally forgot the thing is
this is another important thing
sometimes we'll make dua for things and
we forget that we made dua for them and
then down the line we were given this
bless you know we're given we're given
this Dwyers answered and we don't we've
not even acknowledged that otherwise
been answered
well suppose like you totally forgot
about the time thing I forgot cuz when
he went what time is it also why did you
matter what time it is and when he said
he 351 it's just are they just it was it
was crying it just began to shake I was
so sure yeah we just yeah like I said we
just wanted to share this with you
we were like be like we did not
exaggerate one bit or anything like that
it happened exactly how we did and this
is this is this a message from brother
John and me do I take it seriously you
know and another big point which you
just want to make clear in Islam the Ali
was focusing on debating you know and
other tells in the kind that we're not
accountable for the disbelievers at all
we are only accountable for the reminder
and the reminder is about how he'd is
about Islam so we need to invite and we
need to remind about Islam you know we
don't need to get focused on other
scriptures or other religions let's
invite people to our religion and you
know that the sincere people will
acknowledge this religion and accept the
religion and and we just our serve Allah
to sense and say people to us and keep
the instance a people away from yeah so
thank you very much for watching brother
sisters before we go AB don't Church
just and the main lesson which I was
trying to show Ali's don't Church the
the success of your dour by jihad is
just the success of your tower by how
many people you convey the message and
this is the main that's that's the
reason I do your job know understand
your job if you want the reward for your
job you have to do the job okay
you can't be hired to stock shelves or
stock shelves went and then and then go
and work on the till you know you're not
gonna get paid you know you have to do
your job and your job is to convey the
message of Islam to invite to Islam and
don't forget the invitation you know
literally say would you like to be a
Muslim would you like to accept Islam
and so fun like you'll be surprised how
many people actually say yes yes oh yeah
like I said again thank you very much
for watching and the power of du'a
that's how it that's how I've learned a
lesson myself and inshallah you guys
will benefit from it thank you very much
for watching please support our pages
and be do do offer us powerful to others
thank you